et combats y ont été acharnées ces
dernières heures selon l'armée russe la
ville de carson et donc tomber dans son
escarcelle ces dernières heures c'est
une ville située dans le sud du pays où
les soldats russes progress vous là
découvrez cette ville sur cette carte à
kharkhiv la situation est un peu
différente la pression s'accentue au
moins quatre personnes sont mortes dans
un bombardement et dans la nuit je vous
le disais des soldats ont été à héros
porte est parachuté donc c'est une
nouvelle étape dans cette offensive
menée par vladimir poutine bonjour guily
leurs cracks vous êtes notre envoyé
spécial en ukraine qu'elles sont tout
d'abord les toutes dernières
informations dont vous disposez sur le
terrain
alors pour parler de cette attaque à
archives selon les médias ukrainiens
c'est le bâtiment des services de
sécurité de l'ukraine archives qui a été
touché dans cette dernière frappe les
russes avaient mis en garde qu'il allait
cibler les bâtiments de cette agence
l'agencé de sécurité mais il ya eu aussi
des cibles sur des des attaques sur des
cibles civiles par exemple une maternité
dont la ville de jitomir qui est à 140
km à l'ouest de kiev a été frappée tard
hier soir à ma connaissance c'est la
deuxième maternité qui a été frappé dans
le pays peut être qu'il y en a plus
encore certainement dans les hôpitaux à
travers tout l'ukraine il y a des gens
qui manquent de médicaments qui sont
dont les abris dans les sous sols sous
sol des hôpitaux assaf et c'est l'un des
très nombreux et très très grand un
problème où la vie des personnes en
ukraine est menacée même s'ils ne sont
pas à frapper directement par ces obus
qui tombent les russes disent avoir pris
le contrôle de personnes cela
confirmerait ce que le maire de la ville
disait tu iras la société de presse
comme quoi il avait perdu le contrôle du
port il y à aussi akono top qui est dans
le nord-ouest de l'ukraine sur la route
entre insoumis et kiev là le maire dit
que les russes eux lui ont donné un
ultimatum que soit il doit rendre la
ville à leur force soit il doit soit ils
seront complètement éliminé donc vous
voyez surpris offrant les combats
continus sont très intenses et il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'ukrainiens qui
continue à essayer de se diriger vers
l'ouest comme je le fais actuellement
des ukrainiens qui commence à manquer
d'eau c'est ce qu'on entend notamment du
leader que vous disent les ukrainiens
que vous rencontrez
les iraniens que je rencontre j'en
rencontre beaucoup qui ont un esprit de
résistance très forte je rencontre
beaucoup qui sont très très très en
colère le nombre de fois que j'ai
entendu les mots nous ne pardonnerons
jamais ça c'est un refrain qui résonne
partout en ukraine en ce moment mais je
voulais vous parler d'un sondage qui a
été fait par le rating poupe ce qui
donne peut-être une idée de comment
l'état d'esprit d'une nation peut être
complètement transformé quand il ya une
attaque comme ça selon le rite int poupe
90% des ukrainiens actuellement ont de
l'espoir quant à l'avenir du pays c'est
trois fois plus que la dernière fois
qu'ils ont fait les sondages avant le
début de la guerre 88% pensent qu'au
final lui prenne triomphe fera 93 %
approuvent la conduite du président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky et 98 %
approuvent la conduite des forces armées
ukrainiennes ont parlé d'un pays divisé
avec une partie de la population qui
était plutôt pro-russe les résultats de
ce sondage montre que cette attaque
vraiment transformer l'esprit est aussi
que du moins dans ce qu'ils ont envie de
dire aux sondages heures qui les
appellent parce que bien sûr chacun
pense qu est ce qu il ferait bien de
dire en ce moment mais on voit ses
résultats ac qui montre un pays est pour
le moment en tout cas est vraiment dans
une position de défiance et des
résistances merci beaucoup giver pour
ces tout derniers dernières informations
vous prenez bien